[Musique]
faire évoluer le réseau et l'autre volet
évidemment c'est la promotion du
transport public et notamment la
contribution importante que le
département apporte au financement
d'opérations comme la réalisation de la
ligne T13 on vient de se faire livrer
après de très longues années d'attente
le premier tronçon mais on travaille dès
à présent sur la prolongation de la
ligne T13 vers le nord du département
donc financement d'études réalisations
de travaux et puis le département
accompagne de manière conséquente la fin
de l'opération des halls qui était
évidemment une opération extrêmement
structurante sur lequel à la fois on
co-finance une partie de la réalisation
de l'infrastructure ferroviaire et puis
on investit sur tout ce qui va faciliter
l'accès aux gars puisqu'on considère
c'est vraiment la responsabilité du
département de s'occuper notamment de ce
qu'on appelle le dernier kilomètre
donner envie aux Illinois de déposer
leur vélo leur voiture leur trottinette
près d'une gare et de continuer en train
donc parce qu'on sait que beaucoup des
Vinois n'ont pas le choix ils sont
obligés pour partir de chez eux puisque
vous l'avez dit c'est un territoire
vaste et un peu rural il faut pouvoir
arriver à proximité des lieux transports
en commun se garer sur de retrouver son
véhicule le soir en bon état et voilà
tout ce travail là je sais pas par
l'opération du Saint-Esprit et donc
au-delà des sommes extrêmement
importantes mises dans les
infrastructures ferroviaires et bien la
question des gares et l'aménagement
autour des gars est un sujet qu'on
travaille évidemment avec les communes
mais sur lequel le département est soit
aménageur soit coeur justement vous avez
dit donc les Yvelines c'est aussi très
rural est-ce que vous estimez malgré
tout que l'offre en transport en commun
est suffisante ou est-ce qu'il faudrait
aller un peu plus loin dans les
prochaines années alors elle est
clairement insuffisante et puis soyons
honnêtes la densité de population dans
une partie de notre territoire ne
permettrait pas une personne permettra
sans doute pas avant de longues années
de rendre équilibré des desserts de
transport public pour autant on
travaille vraiment avec les communautés
communes les communautés de déclaration
et l'Île-de-France mobilité qui est
l'autorité organisatrice alors il le
fait mobilité il y a des élus de tous
les départements donc le département il
siège c'est Patrick Stéphanie qui
représente le département donc
évidemment c'est autoritaire
organisatrice pilotée par les politiques
région et départements à vocation à
définir et à faire évoluer
offre de transport public alors on l'a
dit de manière structurante avec du
ferroviaire et old va permettre
d'apporter en plus y compris sur des
zones rurales évidemment un complément
avec de l'offre-bus et en ce moment on
est en train de voir la fin du du Grand
Tour de relance des DSP les délégations
de service public qui attribuent pour
des périodes de 5 à 6 ans la gestion des
réseaux de bus
urbain et interurbain et donc là
l'intérêt romain c'est vraiment le la
zone de prédilection du département et
donc on est en fait attentif à la
manière dont les gens consomment du
transport en commun et on fait évoluer
en tant que besoin cette offre là y
compris vers les territoires ruraux et
le département a récemment voté le
budget pour la modernisation et
l'équipement des routes départementales
on va revenir sur quelques travaux
adréhabitation ou de rénovation
plusieurs opérations déjà commencé en
2022 et se poursuivent en 2023 qu'elles
sont par exemple que c'est ces travaux
alors je me citer quelques-unes il y en
a une assez emblématique parce que ça
fait près de 10 ans que les équipes du
département ils travaillent c'est de
l'aménagement d'un diffuseur qui est à
Vélizy-Villacoublay au sud de du centre
du centre commercial et donc il va
permettre je suis passé enfin sous
l'autoroute sans prendre le terrible
échangeur de Vélizy-Villacoublay que
tous les apprentis du permis de conduire
connaissent parce qu'il y a un centre à
proximité c'est une opération elle est
co-financée publique privée c'est assez
rare 49% public 51% privé donc on a mis
du temps à boucler cette opération
financement parce que il y a 37000
personnes qui travaillent sur cette zone
là dont beaucoup de gros employeurs et
donc on a considéré que c'était assez
légitime que public et privé développe
cet aménagement donc ça c'est une
opération qui va durer
pendant deux ans pour près de 5 millions
d'euros mais voilà c'est assez original
en termes de financement après on
accompagne des opérations comme la
création d'un geratoires à Chambourcy
qui va permettre de desservir de mieux
desservir le son technique municipal de
la ville donc ça c'est de la
co-construction avec la communauté
d'agglomération mais pour un équipement
qui est un équipement d'intérêt public
donc on aménage on aménage ce type de
choses on poursuit l'opération de
réhabilitation du pont de la deuxième
vision blindée qui relie maison la vie
qui est Sartrouville donc ça c'est une
opération de près de 9 millions d'euros
une opération techniquement compliquée
parce que c'est des travaux qui sont
faits en ce qu'on appelle en zone
occupée c'est-à-dire que le pont n'est
pas coupé et en fait on va
soulever le pont changer les
amortisseurs du pont et reposer le pont
sur ces nouveaux amortisseurs ça paraît
assez simple autant vous dire que pour
un pont qui pèse plusieurs centaines de
tonnes avec des véhicules qui roulent
c'est une opération qui va nous prendre
plusieurs années et c'est assez
frustrant parce que c'est pas hyper
spectaculaire vous n'êtes pas en train
de livrer un nouvel ouvrage ça se passe
sous la voie circulation donc on n'est
pas en train de refaire l'infrastructure
avec les gens vont pas voir un nouveau
pont on est en train de solidifier le
pompe à en dessous mais c'est une
opération techniquement assez
intéressante et puis j'en terminerai
là-dessus sur les opérations de pont on
entame les travaux d'aménagement de la
liaison RD 190 RD30 et le pont d'Achères
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre ça
fait ça fait bien tout 40 ans qu'on
parle du pont d'achat et donc on va
entamer les travaux pour livrer des
sites 2027 donc sur quatre ans à la fois
le pont et la voirie ce qui va permettre
vraiment de d'améliorer
significativement les circulations
Est-Ouest sur cette partie du
département mais c'est vraiment des
travaux de très longue haleine et la
création d'un nouveau pont sur la scène
c'est pas non plus une opération qu'on
fait chaque année donc il y a quelque
chose d'assez d'assez excitant à l'idée
de livrer cette ouvrage là il y a aussi
l'amélioration de 4 carrefours à
Guyancourt et Voisins-le-Bretonneux leur
renforcement de la rd119 et
l'installation d'une passerelle
provisoire à Poissy 3 autres opérations
devraient également voir le jour pour un
budget total de 9,8 millions d'euros on
ne se rend pas toujours compte justement
de l'importance de ces travaux pourquoi
sont-ils sont-ils nécessaires ils sont
je les dis nécessaires pour permettre de
tenir compte de l'évolution des
mobilités beaucoup de nos
infrastructures routières elles ont été
pensées dans les années 50-60 certaines
ont été pensées mais n'ont pas été
faites donc elle manque aujourd'hui et
puis les règles ont changé les les
contrats d'environnemental sont beaucoup
plus forts que dans les années 50-60 et
pour autant si on ne fait rien on sait
que dans 5 ou 10 ans il y a des zones
qui vont être complètement embolisées et
donc on essaie d'anticiper on essaie
d'anticiper pour corriger ce qui peut
l'être alors on Coach de deux manières
on investissant effectivement dans des
infrastructures routières mais elles
sont de plus en plus compliquées à
insérer dans le paysage et en incitant
par de l'investissement dans les
transports publics nos administrer nos
concitoyens à continuer à se déplacer
mais autrement et donc on en revient au
grand projet d'un frein ferroviaire qui
demain vont venir irriguer de manière
plus efficace le département et sans
doute permettre à des gens qui
aujourd'hui utilisent intégralement la
voiture de faire une combinaison voiture
transport public et une des grandes
inquiétudes dans dans les Yvelines c'est
par rapport aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui qui approchent et
certains Yvelines noires donc sont
inquiet déjà dans les transports en
commun le risque est d'avoir une
influence une influence pardon extrême
avec une cohabitée cohabitation entre
les visiteurs des jo-p 2024 et les
travailleurs et dans un second temps une
information qui est passée un petit peu
inaperçue mais c'est la restriction de
plusieurs axes routiers en Île-de-France
entre juillet et septembre le
département des Yvelines semble toucher
en tout cas aux dernières nouvelles on a
l'axe qui relie Boulogne-Billancourt à
Rocancourt qui sera fermé le deuxième
axe se situe à 50 ans en Yvelines qui
relie Bailly et Montigny-le-Bretonneux
comment est-ce que vous pouvez rassuré
justement les yvelin qui iront
travailler à cette période là en se
disant ils vont quand même pouvoir aller
au travail malgré le monde alors ils
pourront aller au travail on va remettre
les choses en perspective effectivement
vous l'avez rappelé il y a deux épreuves
il y a les JO classique entre guillemets
selon lieu la première quinzaine d'août
c'est normalement la période où les
Franciliens sont plutôt engagés pas tous
mais plutôt en congé donc la
cohabitation entre les actifs qui
travaillent en Île-de-France et les le
public dont on espère qu'il sera quand
même assez nombreux on attend sur sur le
site du château de Versailles par
exemple 14000 visiteurs par jour et
40000 le jour du cross donc on sait on a
la volumétrie parce que il y a des
billets vendus donc on sait ce qu'on
doit accueillir comme visiteur on sait
que c'est une période de l'année où on a
effectivement moindre besoin en termes
de déplacement pour pour les actifs donc
cette partie là ne nous inquiète pas
trop celle qui nous a été un peu plus ce
sont vous l'avez rappelé les Jeux
paralympiques parce que eux ils ont lieu
juste à la rentrée scolaire et là ça va
être un peu plus compliqué de faire
comme idée tout le monde mais chaque
jour suffit sa peine on travaille en ce
moment donc à effectivement au modalités
de transport des sportifs de tous les
gens qui vont travailler autour des JO
et puis du public en tenant compte vous
l'avez dit d'un certain nombre de
restrictions alors vous avez évoqué des
actes qui serait possiblement condamnés
vous n'avez pas évoqué des voix qui vont
être dédiées au covoiturage sur des
autoroutes certaines irriguent
départements et puis effectivement le
principe général qui est retenu par le
Comité international olympique c'est que
les publics est invité à se déplacer
massivement en transport en commun donc
normalement il y aura peu mais on sait
qu'il y en aura on sait qu'il y en aura
donc on travaille avec les villes
concernées évidemment le vélo de
Saint-Quentin et les épreuves qui ont
lieu au Château de Versailles sont deux
spots sur lequel on travaille depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois mais là on
rentre vraiment dans la partie
extrêmement fine puisque les règles du
jeu sont à peu près stabilisées et donc
on est en train de travailler au report
modal entre l'arrivée en train qui va
être privilégiée pour beaucoup de de
touristes la fin de parcours en vélo
notamment on va mettre en place en nous
des services de vélo puisque les voiles
sont interdites à la circulation mais
peut-être réservées pour certaines modes
doux justement on pourra de toute façon
en revenir dans une autre émission pour
parler plus en détail de tout ce que
vous avez prévu pour faciliter on va
dire au maximum la vie des visiteurs et
faire la mobilité des visiteurs et des
50 chinois et des yvelinois on parlera
également dans une autre dans une autre
émission de la rénovation des pistes
cyclables voulues par le Département
merci beaucoup Richard Delpierre d'avoir
été avec nous sur sensation pour plus
d'informations peut se rendre sur le
site yvelines.fr et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]